- This is some like, Instagram
model sh-- (beeping).
(lively music)
Baking is a makeup technique
that was invented by drag queens
to make their makeup stay
on their faces longer.
A celebrity makeup
artists have been doing it
to big celebrities like Kim Kardashian
and I don't know, are
there any other celebrities
that matter?
The heat from your face
mixing with the oils,
it comes through your skin
and it takes about 10 minutes
for the whole process to happen
and that's how you get baked.
(bell dings)
In order to bake your face
you need a liquid concealer,
beauty blender,
soft brushes, translucent powder,
sponges.
- I thought baking was
just applied to, like,
making cakes.
- You have something
very hot near your face,
like a lava lamp.
- A makeup thing that
involves a lot of makeup
and like, a decent amount of time.
- Part of it is that I'm
a little bit intimidated
by makeup, I mean, look at this.
(laughing) This is terrifying.
- My mom says things to me like,
"It wouldn't kill you to wear some blush
"once in a while."
- I just don't think I
can do anything on my face
with any level of precision,
but we'll see, we'll see.
You know, I'm full of surprises.
The other day I ate a banana.
And I don't like bananas.
- Step one, apply liquid concealer
under your eyeballs.
- And then you put it here on, ooo.
You put it (laughing)
do I look pretty yet?
- This is actually kind
of like therapeutic.
- I feel like a five year old.
- She didn't put any on her mustache,
but I kind of want to.
- Blend this by just
pressing it into my skin
in sort of a beating motion,
like, just beat the sh--(beeping)
out of your own face.
- And then you take an
undescended testicle
and rub it in.
- Oh f--(beeping) no (laughing).
The first thing I'm concerned
about when I wake up
is like, where is breakfast and like,
is there something clean enough
for me to wear to work.
- (laughing) Exactly look like she looks.
- So at this point, you want to take
your beauty blender or
your triangular sponge
and you are going to dip it
into the translucent powder
and apply it all over where
you put that concealer.
And that's really where the
"baking" technique comes in.
- Oooo. (coughing).
(sneezing)
- Now I'm looking more
and more like a mime.
- So for oilier skin types,
you're actually going to see those oils
coming out through the translucent powder
so that's where the term
'baking' comes from.
That's how you know you're cooked.
- And now we bake.
- While you're waiting
for your face to bake,
it would be a good time to finish
the rest of your team,
put your eyebrows on fleek,
maybe pour yourself a nice glass of rosé.
(bell dings)
- If you look closely at my skin
you can see that my natural oils
have sort of, like, blended a little bit
with the powder and I haven't even, like,
touched it with a brush
and that's pretty cool.
- I like to use a clean blush brush
or a eyeshadow brush.
So I'm just gonna go ahead and go
right in here.
- In makeup videos,
everyone makes this face.
And they just do a lot of this
when they're doing it so,
I don't have to make this face.
I just wanna capture the aesthetic.
- She makes it look like there's like,
a grace or an art to the brush stroke.
- This looks crazy.
It looks like I'm the old ghost.
(bell dings)
- And it's that easy.
And by easy, I mean
like, not easy.
- Like, it's fun to have like,
weird sh--(beeping) on your face
and just to be able to,
like, play with brushes
and just make yourself look
a little bit more done up
than you normally would.
- This is probably the one makeup style
where I could actually
see myself doing this.
- It takes a lot of time and
it's not particularly pleasant.
It's like, I don't like
breathing in powder
and like, sitting with
tons of makeup on my face.
I think, if you're into it, like, great,
just not for me.
- When I see other kinds of makeup,
you kind of, sometimes
it feels like you lose
the person and it's
like, it looks like them
but it's not them.
Where as, I look at this and I'm like,
oh, I still see me and I like me.
So it's good to see me.
(laughing)
(lively music)